ch
[Music]
for e
good evening
welcome Happy new
year thank you all for being with us
today I want to extend a special welcome
to all of you who are new or just here
for the first time in a very long time
I'm so glad that you've chosen to join
us
today my name is cat my pronouns are she
and
her and we're happy you're here these
candles are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us fully
Divine and fully
human as most of you have
heard there was a terrible
that occurred in the City of New Orleans
earlier this week over a dozen people
were killed and many were
injured would you please join me for a
moment of quiet and
prayer as we hold all of those directly
touched by the attack in our hearts
now we exit the kingdom of
noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
Grace now we enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer worship and adoration a space to
encounter
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find
you to mend your
heart may we all come home
would you guys stand with us as we
worship
tonight just reminding ourselves after
um reflecting on just the tragedy of
that event that took place and even
reflecting back on some of the painful
moments from 2024
um you know every year holds so much
inside of it and for many of us there
were a lot of great wonderful Highs but
also some things that I've looked back
on and you know that are painful um or
challenges that had to be overcome
sickness um loss um and I'm sure we all
are bringing that into this space
together and I hope that the words of
this song Encourage your heart as they
of mine that God is holding us and all
of our broken pieces in the palm of his
hand and um whether we are whole tonight
or whether we're coming in a little
broken um there is space and room for it
all so let's worship together um with
that in mind
[Music]
not easy let
goting
[Music]
you
know you
you it's not easy let go and TR you
[Music]
so I will stop Brea rest here in your
goodness I know
you it's my confidence confidence I will
stop Brea rest here in your goodness I
know
you it's my confidence confidence
[Music]
let's sing that
again
out
I my
def no it's not easy let
[Music]
go you
I know that you said you
got It's Not
Easy
Go
[Music]
you I will stop Brea rest here in your
goodness I know you w it's my confidence
confidence I will St Brea rest here in
your goodness I know you won't it's my
confidence here I
am nothing can take me away nothing can
take me
I am in the of
your nothing can take me away nothing
can take me away
[Music]
not a height not
a
[Music]
a not a
lie not a fear
or let's sing it again not a
not a lie inside my head not a fear or
off Take Me
Away not a hide or a death not a lie
inside my head not a fear or a
[Music]
f nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
here I
[Music]
am nothing take
away here I am in
the nothing Take Me Away nothing can
take me away oh here I am in the palm of
your head nothing can take me away
nothing can take me
away here I am in the palm of your hand
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away my confidence confidence
it's my confidence confidence it's my
confidence it's my confidence confence
it's my confidence
oh it's my confidence confidence it's my
confidence confidence nothing can take
[Music]
me all right you kiddos are dismissed to
go to your classrooms and your teachers
will meet you over there by the
door thank you guys for helping out
tonight Maggie and I think Charles and
Chloe
a
oops one of those days oh it'ss all
right we're going to go ahead and
transition into the prayer of the people
um and if this is your first time with
us tonight this is a um practice that
was popular throughout Christian history
that we want to bring into our services
just to make space for what you're
carrying into this room um um The Good
the Bad and the Ugly we want to hold
those up before God together and um and
make room to name those because we
believe that's important um and that he
cares and and we care as a community for
one another so if you guys would follow
along on the screens and read the parts
that are in red with
us Jesus for the city of saxi Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for The Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you for the old and the sick for the
Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen Christ is my firm foundation
The Rock on I stand when around
sh
I've glad I my faith in
Jesus he's
never me down he's faithful through
generations
[Music]
so why would he
now
he no he won't no he
won't I've still got joy
in i' got peace that makes no sense so I
won't be going
I'm not H by My Own Strength cuz I put
my life on
Jesus and he's never let me down he's
faithful in every
[Music]
season so why would he fa
now he
he
won he won't
[Music]
fil he won't
fail
he
he he won
[Music]
won't Christ is my firm
foundation The Rock on I stand
everything around me
[Music]
Shing I've never been more
glad I put my faith in Jesus
and he's never let me down faithful
[Music]
through so why would he fail
now he
[Music]
W he
W he won't fail
he won't
[Music]
fail he
won't no he
won't he
won't he won't
[Music]
fail he won't
fail he w
[Music]
rain came
wind but my house was built on
you and I'm safe with
[Music]
itain
came my was buil on
you and I'm safe with you I'm going to
make it
through came
[Music]
my bu on
you with you I'm going to make
it I'm going to make
it I'm standing strong on
you I'm going to make it through
my buil on you Christ is my
Foundation The Rock on I
stand everything around me is
Shen i'
never more glad I put my faith in Jesus
he never let me down faithful through
gender so why would he fail
now
[Music]
he he
he
all
fear
of oh my heav
[Music]
for this will be my
song you are always
good I'll sing it all day
long you are always
good and when the day is through
now I am left with you
are you are
always
good you meet me on the mountain
top you see me in the valley
[Music]
low there is no home without you
here and I find you in the crowed
thoughts you quiet all the question
marks there is no space Your Love Won't
f
[Music]
I'll trade all of my fear for peace of
M and all my
heaviness for burdens
life and this will be my
song you are always good
I sing it all day
long you are always
good and when the day is
through and I am left with you
[Music]
are you
are there
me
Mel you're singing back to me you're
singing
Melo you're singing back to me you're
singing Back
M you're singing back to me you're
singing back I traded all my fear
forace
[Music]
my you took
heav
my this will be
[Music]
sing it all day
long you are always
good when the day is
through I am left with you are
[Music]
you
are
good thank you Lord for your faithful
love you are steadfast
you are a
rock you lift us out of the muck and the
Meer and you set our feet on steady
ground thank you for being a
shelter and a
refuge and thank you God that you take
our
fear and you can transform it into
peace that you can take our
worry and give us confidence in a love
that does not end in a hope that will
not give
out you are a good God and we sink
ourselves we anchor ourselves into that
truth as we begin a new year with new
problems and new
victories we remember God that you are
good we remember that you are our
source and we turn our eyes to our
maker Our
Savior our redeem
humor our everpresent help in times of
trouble God would your word ring in our
ears this
year would we remember the truths that
you have spoken over
[Music]
us and would that love transform not
only our own lives but the lives around
us
would it transform our community our
church the way that we love the way that
we make
room the way that we engage this
world in Jesus name
amen would you guys go ahead and welcome
the people around you and say hello to
your neighbors and then we'll keep
rolling
well
welcome Grace and peace my name is Brett
and the pastor here and it's so good to
be with you all and to welcome you
welcome you
yeah to welcome you into this space
really glad uh glad to be with you it's
a new year here we are some of you are
like woohoo you're excited you're pumped
some of you are like I'm limping in
limping in
2025 and you know whatever it is like
that's that's okay you know God Christ
meets us there in the midst of it and
it's beautiful and good so um also
before I forget I want to welcome those
join us online love you lots and uh and
especially anyone who's new thanks for
for being here and uh being Among Us so
uh tonight's a really special night
because it is H it's what we call story
Sunday here at the table we always we
try to do these a little more often now
used to be just once a year we do it
like on this day um the first Sunday of
the year but um it's a it's an important
practice for us here because one of our
values um is to be communal and by that
we mean I mean something like love in
Rel in a relational sense so it's kind
of the idea of you know we want to
commune with God to have that sense of
connection in love and then we want that
to like flow you know from us or from
God through us to others and to commune
with other people and um I like that
word though communit I don't know it
feels a little
richer than just you know being like
being relational you know or even I
don't know there's something a little
cliche maybe about the word love you're
saying we want to be a loving Church
like well of course but um you know to
to to commune like well in essence to do
that well uh you do have to know
people you know you can't like have a
sense of communion connection and be
like yeah I don't really know them don't
know what's going on there that story is
you so that's part of story Sunday is a
chance for us to go a little deeper you
know maybe you're going to hear aspects
of someone's story that who knows unless
you're like in a Meetup with them or
something you know you might it might be
a few years before you ever realize like
oh my gosh you went through what you
know or whatever and so that's kind of
what these days are about is a chance to
hear um something a little bit deeper
from folks so uh with that in mind I'd
like to
begin by inviting up Miss Vicki Ferris
would y'all give her a hand as she comes
forward
Miss Vicki is my friend I um the church
I grew up at her and her then husband
Wally attended it so she she knew me as
like a little like a little PR and she
is wonderful
you I'll join you
um say test test test test it's working
it's working so good so um Miss Vicky I
don't I hope everyone knows her but if
not I'm very excited for you to get to
have this opportunity because he is
wonderful but could you start off just
by sharing you know a little bit of your
kind of background you know your your
your history like where where did you
grow up and um do you have kids and you
know just all
that before I give you all that Bing
information for the last
year words that scrub have f for the
last year and they're not fun words
they're not fun at all
I've been in a really dark dark place um
painful and sad and
uh felt desolation and
sorrowful I've been disappointed and
hopeless Melancholy like thank you so
much because I with
that and very very weepy so I will do
some weeping
thank I will do some weeping here I
apologize sometime I get knows and stuff
like that just forgive me and bear with
me because I do have something to say
other than just about my life um I um
I've never been in this dark of a place
before it's new to me and um I wish i'
shared it before I shared probably more
with breath than I've shared with anyone
but I I tend to want to be that old
blue-haired lady that's always happy and
I'm not always that person not always
that person but um if I had shared this
before maybe I wouldn't be in this place
I don't know I haven't been in church in
a while because I have been sick and and
it's amazing how the music makes you
just so happy tears of joy tears of joy
and I've enjoyed it so much this morning
I feel like maybe I am back I don't know
but at anyway
um I want you to listen to my story and
say how normal it is normal compared to
everybody else I mean we're all close to
the same you know close to the same but
my story is not being lost and finding
God and being happy happy happy that's
not my story I've been awfully happy in
my life I have been that's and I have to
read these notes because I'm old and I
can't remember anything so forgive me
for that
um but as I said before by sharing more
perhaps I wouldn't be in the place that
I'm at now I don't
know but I grew up in a little bitty
town MA Texas near Texas can had 26
people in my graduating class if that
tells you anything about where I grew up
and when I was 11 I lost my dad and um
the village and my mother raised me the
village raised all of us it was a
wonderful childhood it just was
everybody loved you and I know before I
got home my mother was going no I had
already done that but it was always in
love it was not trying to get me in
trouble or anything like that it was
always in love so it's kind of how I was
raised and
um now um grew up with a group of people
from elementary all through college even
now I'm in touch with them and and I
went to college and after college I got
married and and then had a couple of
kids Jing
whitning
um my only sibling
passed away two days after Whitney was
born and then I lost my mom in
1991 and then God took one of my
children I never thought that would
happen but he took one of my children he
took her J he had Graves disease and he
was a delightful young man anybody that
knew him always had a smile on his face
he was always happy he's he was a good
boy but he was 26 when he died and he
left behind two children both W under
two and U they talk about him all my
grandkids talk about him when they knew
him because of Whitney I think she's
been so attending and living to her own
children and his children and it's kind
of interesting when I they talk about
him because I didn't know him at all but
I I love
that but that was very difficult for all
of us
but I I was the strong one at the time
um my husband never really got over that
never never got over
it and I think that probably he become a
different person he wasn't the same
anymore but the one that was hardest on
was Whitney I wasn't sure she was going
to survive that I wasn't sure the very
very close he kind of raised her my
husband was in bed sick and I was trying
to earn a living and and he did a fair
job she turned out
okay she's a great great daughter and
she's a wonderful mother and
teacher and I'm very very proud of her
although he do agree many
areas she's all right with
me after she died quitting she just had
a baby and I didn't know what she was
going to do I thought what how am I
going to help her she went put herself
through college got a degree and took
Sienna her little baby with her where
she went and she turned into a wonderful
young woman those of you who don't know
her you need to know her she's pretty
funny she's a little
fasty but we can go with that go
that I like her fast
though but that was really really hard
for her but she just picked herself up
and went on it still hard for her but
all six of my grandchildren know him
like they knew him because of her
because she has loved them and taken
care of them and it's just it's just who
she is just who she
is
um after
um we lost him I had already started
working at the the school in Al worked
there for 20 years Story Elementary if
anybody knows where Story Elementary is
I wor there for 20 years I did speech
therapy and I did a last schills class
and I did English as a second language
and when I retired I did not want to my
body just wouldn't go anymore you know
just sometimes you just can't go anymore
but it it was great it was great I loved
it I'd still be doing it today if I
could but in 20
I was diagnosed with Parkinson's disease
and and most people think oh you have
Tremors no that's not even part of it
it's the strangest disease I've ever
seen it's different for everybody and it
kind of makes me a little bit crazy I
don't know if you noticed that but it
does
make You' noticed it I'm sure but it's
real different and you never know when I
wake up in the morning I don't know what
it's going to be never know what it's
going to be
me but um I
just got involved I guess about that
time know it was later than that I got
involved in the church and um and of
course Co rose up and showed us how ugly
it was and and at that time I started
reading my Bible more than I ever had
before I I have anything else to do you
know read my Bible and pray my
relationship with God tremendously I
didn't know he was a loving God I had no
idea I up a Baptist Church in you know
East Texas Hell Fire bromstone that's
what we were taught I didn't know I
didn't know what a loving God he
is after I
met all the people at the table and I've
met some really dear dear friends and
some of you have not met and I'm I am
crazy I'll go ahead and admit that but
it's part of the disease you know that's
what I said
but I was just happy as I could be happy
happy happy happy I was mostly I am
happy I'm just sharing some things with
y'all tonight I not shared with anyone
else I um after I got involved in the
church and and it was it's been bright
it's been bright it's been
wonderful I started kind of going
downhill and I knew something was
happening I wasn't sure I just wasn't
sure what was happening
and that's where the struggles I'm in
right now that's where they began as I
look back that's where it began but I
like to be happy and I like everybody
think I'm happy and and no worri s like
that
but I I was in a lot of pain had a lot
of things going not for me but any rate
this none of this makes any sense
probably but
I just want to let y'all know that we
need to share these things with each
other we need to share these things with
people this is our family this is our
community and you have no idea I want to
bang my head up against a wall every
time I woke up because I wouldn't tell
anybody that now you all
know but that's really why I'm here
tonight is is to let you know there's
somebody here if you need to share
there's somebody here that will listen
Maybe they've experienced the same thing
I don't know know but I wish I'd shared
it
earlier because I try to fight all my
battles alone because I'm so
tough and I'm not tough at all not tough
at
all but that's really why I wanted to
speak to my this make any sense to
you good it's a good word because we we
need to share we need to know each other
more I mean I know your faces and some
of I I know know pretty well but we need
to share our ins Sons this is our family
this is our family and we need to share
what we feel cuz none of us are perfect
we don't live that life you know happy
happy happy we don't there's no such
thing but God helps us about those bad
on and fortunately have not lost my
faith there were days I begged him to
take me come on let's go today he
wouldn't take me at one time he said no
can't take you to that so he's got some
kind of purpose for me I'm not sure what
it is to be happy again I just moved in
with my daughter and her children and
we're just all tickled I'm tickled I
don't know if they are but I'm tickled
about but really that that's what I came
to say is that we need we need to know
each other and share with each other and
love one another and we all have
difficulties and there's somebody in
this room that will understand that
there's somebody somewhere in this
family that will understand
yet and that's all I have to say I think
I'm done
thank you Vicky thank you for Sharon you
really are
um you are a treasure here you are a
treasure and I know there's a part of
you that wants oh no but for real every
time you walk through those doors I'm
like a little bit excited I'm just like
yes this he's feeling good enough to be
here today and I don't it's honestly
it's beyond words I don't think I can
quite articulate what your presence
means but you
I and and I'll name this too you have
like you said you've always been a
person with a certain joy and even in
the midst of I mean tremendous pain and
struggles you know she can you can show
it with a smile on your face but I do
love how in the last year or so you have
been pushing more into that authenticity
and that vulnerability and that you know
honestly not so good today Brett you
know and that is that's a gift too that
that kind of honesty it's it's an
example for all of us so yeah so we love
you so much and are so glad that you're
a part of this this community yall give
her a
[Applause]
hand all
right next
tonight uh I want to invite up someone
who uh although you may not recognize
him he has seen I mean pretty much every
sermon preached every worship song sung
he's heard it every prayer prayed he's
heard it uh because he hosts our online
uh Community week after week after week
after week after week after week after
week for like I mean he joined super
soon after the table started so it's
been a solid I don't know like five
years or something I mean need just
keeps doing it so um you give a hand for
James
Townsen is there like a fiveyear jacket
you get or something some I know we need
some sort of like uh award or or
something yes and also before I forget I
want to acknowledge that his mother
Nancy is here as well so really glad
that you're you're here so um Jes give
us a little uh a little background you
know for those who uh you're a new face
and what's your a little bit of your
story how'd you grow up all that yeah
that's why you're wondering why does he
have a computer over there because I'm
hosting the online group there's about
10 or so people hi people uh on there
and U they were loving what Vicki said
um
I had a I watched Wicked this week I
finally got to watch it so this was was
supposed to be muted online but I had my
alphaba moment and I'm going to defy
gravity so I to texted him and I said
let it ride let it play so because I I
took him from I grew up in Dallas area
here Pleasant Grove my parent Mom and
Dad who've been married he's only 63
years uh they're still he's at the
sister living she's there too uh we grip
Dallas but they've lived in Mount
Pleasant for 30 something years so
afterwards y'all can just the two rators
just find each other uh but I grew up
here in the Dallas area uh Church of
Christ so once saved barely
saved uh you know it was a concept of if
you you know those I see a lot of head
nodding you know what I'm talking about
that you weren't excited because you
weren't sure if you were
really committed if like am I really
saved so if I'm not really sure have a
ticket on this ride why am I going to go
out and like say hey here's a ticket it
may work it may not I don't know and uh
it it was just interesting so always
kind of feeling you know those of you
that have been through this feeling that
you never uh as much as you try you're
never going to do enough to earn your
salvation so to then have feelings of
being you know same seex attraction and
like oh no no no this is this is a no no
they've been talking about that you know
because there were very distinct groups
talked about it Conservative Christian
churches and I he had dotting again you
just knew were off limits so suppress
suppress suppress as much as as you can
and pray that God just takes it away
because there must be something wrong U
my dad and I did not get along very well
growing up because I felt like there was
something he didn't give me
uh as a boy that you know I didn't learn
how to play sports didn't how to play
foot play football maybe that's what it
was I didn't get that testosterone burst
that you're supposed to have as a as a
kid well later from football what from
football like that's the key yeah yeah
says the coach
that uh and at some point my myma told
me she's like hey you're dad never
learned to play sports because his
father and I was like oh yeah that's
right we don't have a real big history
of this so that's not it and did
counseling and just you know kept
looking for a
cause uh I felt like there was some
there's got to be something that made me
feel this
way because that can't be consistent
with you can't be gay and be a Christian
that's just not not possible but over
the years and I went to college and I
still suppressed
suppressed uh I hit that point where I'm
like okay I I've prayed and I believe as
many of you do that God answers prayers
either yes no or not yet I mean you I'm
not going to do a show of hands but
that's typically are there any other
options okay so if you believe that God
answers prayers and he's not ignoring
you then he has told me no repeatedly to
take these feelings
away and I'm like what the
hell I mean what I I mean like you know
if you think you know is this Divine
invention or is this me and then you
read the Left Behind books and you're
like oh God you know what so it's again
I've heard every one of his sermons uh I
realized in my late
20s okay if God's not going to take this
away then there's got to be some way
that he can be glorified or some way he
can Something Good Can Come of this okay
is me beating myself up I mean the world
beats you up about it directly and
indirectly I don't need to be beating
myself up about this so how can I be
both gay and a Christian and make this
work and so over the years you know uh
share with a number of people you know
privately and uh families and you nobody
rejected I mean I have some people I
don't talk to as much uh talked to my
family at one point that was an
interesting conversation for a whole
another day uh and I she probably still
thinks it's a phase I'm going through
but uh I'm a little over the phase but
uh and so that's why I've tried to find
some way to say it's okay to be both uh
you don't have to put yourself in a box
so it was probably five something years
ago that I I think I was on the
centerpiece webinar during before Co or
around covid time and you did a session
and you're like hi I'm Pastor Brad that
I don't think I talk like that okay
you're you're bubbly like it's a little
deeper he is Jess's got he's a little
bit hey that's you know a little Harry
Cary hey we're we're in Saxy Texas and
we're the table and so I was like hey my
parents just got you know mov to saxi I
have some family in that area how cool
so I checked it out and again during Co
and then
over time we talked and met for coffee
and you're like hey well since you're
living away and you're in the online why
don't you do the online thing so I
prepped the weekly sermon slides and
announcements and that slide I prepped
for
myself and uh that's true he did it's
it's very different being here than
sitting in my recliner in my
pajamas can I co go back to the um
impression the well the coming out okay
the coming out side of it like
uh who who were some of the first people
you told like how how did it how was it
just being you know gay and
Christian how did you navigate that like
how how did it impact you yeah well I
went to abene Christian went to a
Christian School and again affiliated
with Churches of Christ but was a little
bit more uh left of center on some
things and I just said okay I'm going to
I have some friends I sang on worship
team I've been active at the church I've
taught youth ministry College Ministries
worship teams and I'm like I felt like I
could trust them and I just said hey I
need to share something because I'm
going to explode if I don't and so I sat
down and I kind of went through a little
my journey and they were like okay is
that what you came over and I was like
you're not
like standing up walking out you're not
throwing things at me you're not opening
up the Bible and quoting scripture to me
they're like no no well well let us
share a little bit of our marriage and
about some of the struggles we have and
I was like okay and I went home and I
walked out and I was like well that was
weird like they did not reject me they
in fact became
closer because they were in an inner
circle of trust and you know I'm still
good friends with them
today how um what's it like as you're
still there Mount Pleasant um a little
more rural
you
know touch and you know they your your
special education
teacher um also there's the church
element where you go online here you
know and there's a full back story there
so I'm just wondering like what's it
like to be a gay man there in Mount
Pleasant like what's that what's that
experience like well I'll be honest it's
lonely uh because you know not a lot of
clubs for even straight you know even
just to hang out there uh but
it's a matter of
uh connecting with others is what I what
I love the most about the table is that
and I was trying to tell family about
this to say you know you guys planted
this church and um you know wanted to be
accepting and welcoming for all the
church I was going to a Baptist Church
for a while there in Mount Pleasant and
they every year they'd have you sign
something that says okay this is what
you agree to
and we will not stray from this one man
one woman for life they kind of forget
the for Life thing and stick with you
know that and I would sign it I was like
you know he was like you know uh you
know you they pick and choose but I had
a lot of connections and over the years
have not just there but when I was in
abene and Long View and Illinois in
Indiana people had opportunities for me
to say listen what whatever you're upset
about I can can top it I can you know
let me tell you my journey and it would
disarm them to say oh my gosh I felt
that same way I'd never have shared that
with anybody and I'm like well you found
a trusting place so there's a lot of
hurting people out there and uh it's
it's lonely because you have to make
that choice when you say okay I can be
gay and Christian it doesn't mean you
get to break all the rules you know the
uh behavioral rules in
relationships but it also doesn't mean
that you have to be abstinent for the
rest of your life that and I've said you
know if the right person comes along
that's great um the whole God's timing
thing I'm going still a little bit you
know struggling on um and I think I was
telling you the other day I I feel like
I'm more of a theist and I hope I'm
using this in the right context and that
I I feel like if if God's if God's
answering every thing that's happening
if everything that happens is either
will God allow those people in New
Orleans you know let's just be honest
did he allow that or did he cause it oh
he took them early did he really take
them it's a whole other sermon I know
but are we where we are because God
wanted us to be here or God allowed it
to be here I think he kind of set the
world down this is my new feeling he's s
like okay put you guys there give you
the rules spin it that he's kind of
watching from a distance that's just me
now um still believe he
exists but for him to say no to so many
things uh it kind of confuses me and
confuses those that are saying listen I
want to be gay and worship Jesus but how
can they get along but at some point you
just have to say listen you know it is
what it is yeah it sounds like for you
it's it's been kind of a very
practical Journey you know of of it's
been a heart Journey in terms of trying
to come to grips with okay well this is
who I am this seems to be how I'm wired
and I can't change that I prayed for it
and uh and you've kind of just worked it
through and and I don't know I get the
sense have you is it kind of a making
peace with it so to speak like the the
canundrum a little bit of like oh well I
don't know about certain Christian
theologies and things and being gay and
I don't know how to make intellectual
sense of all that and it's is there a
certain you've come to peace with it is
that a good description or is it
something else how would you describe it
no I think that that moment where you go
you're like I'm going to stop running
away from who I am and what's behind me
and run towards it and just say okay
let's work with it this is what I've got
and this I want say you know the whole
this is the card you were dealt uh
concept but this is what card I've been
dealt in life and whether I want to deny
it or not I wouldn't want to trade cards
with you I wouldn't want to know what
your struggles are and deal with that
I'm think I'm uniquely positioned to
deal with this in a way that no body
else can I think I told you when we
talked that there are people who have
gone through very emotional very some
physical Journeys that I can't relate to
ladies there's a lot of things I cannot
relate to you on and only those of us
that have been through that can say hey
here's where we are here was our journey
let us help you so I'm at peace with it
absolutely I mean it's not like I'm like
that little bit of Church Christ is
always stuck in your head because it's
like a bug and it's like you know are
you sure are you sure
but no I I have that peace and that
confidence that says um that it's for a
reason yeah yeah last question about
like kind of your whole online role I've
wondered I mean you've done it for so
long now week after
week what is kind of kept you with that
you know I mean I even think of of folks
who try to do online church and maybe
fade away after a while you know and and
what's not only kept you attending
online but like in that role and and
what's yeah what's the driver that check
you send me each week
no just
kidding all the other volunteers are
like way to I'm surprised my mic didn't
get cut off at that point no uh we're
not paid
uh one it's a way I can contribute to
something that I believe in and the
online audience is very uh unique in
that it's not like you go to any other
online service and they're like hey
y'all how you doing and very you know
chitchat about the day and the weather
ours is very discreet there's a few that
will say like tonight somebody said
greetings from Virginia and I was like
hey how much snow is there and they
answered back Raymond you will respond
back but most people are just kind of
like in that sense of I'm just
observing they're taking the first step
online which may lead how many of you
watched online before you came here in
person okay several of you uh it's just
trying to be there present information
and just let them know they're welcome I
usually post something about you're
welcome just as you are at the table and
there's a song that I think we sing that
the crowded table that one that says I
would to be uh at a place with a you
with a with a crowded table and I'm like
that is us I I like sang it repeatedly
in the car and I'm like that's what I
want is where everybody's welcome to the
table so much so we got to make the
table a bigger
table well James I'm just grateful for
not only you just sharing vulnerably but
also way you have been so faithful there
I um it's such a it's such a behind the
scenes kind of thing you know and I
don't know there's something in us like
as humans we want to be recognized and
we want to you know so for him to do
that for so many years like I just think
that says a lot about who you are and U
we're yeah like so many people have
benefited and received something from
that so thank you so much for doing that
and for sharing would youall give him a
hand to
[Applause]
well um tonight we're going to go ahead
and transition into
communion and participate in that and
it's it's kind of a chance you know
having uh Vicky and James share love
hearing their stories and obviously it'
be great if we could like here everyone
and uh obviously we can't so some of um
I want you to do as you come forward
with with communion is to kind of be
whatever's on your heart you know this
year like to kind of bring it with you
and uh you'll notice we have these uh
candles kind of lined up um usually I
say when you partake a communion you can
take immediately you can return to your
seats can do whatever you want tonight I
want to encourage you as you come
forward to partake right away and then
just leave the cup here you can see
behind the candles there's little spaces
for your cups and you just put it there
and then what the candles are going to
be representative of is it can be kind
of two things one um maybe it's a symbol
of some sort of um pain or grief or
struggle from
2024 that you're kind of giving to God
or maybe the candle can be uh kind of a
prayer a hope for yourself for someone
else for
2025 and so you can just take it pick it
up and use you know one of these candles
to kind of light it um and uh yeah we
just wanted to to kind of open up space
for each of us to be able to process
even in just a little way uh kind of Our
Own Story tonight um so the way we're
going to partake of communion um is
we'll start here at the the front and
we'll just form one line right here in
the middle and we'll kind of just go row
by row by row so when one Row's down you
can just uh the next row can jump in we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
have a desire to participate even if you
maybe don't know all the ins and outs of
Christian theology uh or you know are
part of a particular denomination and
you wonder like oh can I take communion
here um just know we have an open table
so um you're welcome to participate in
this time you should know that the red
is wine and the white is grape juice and
uh and then finally like I said you can
partake immediately and then just kind
of head over here and light a candle and
have that uh that moment of prayer so
this is the
table not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to follow and
you who have failed come come because
it's the Lord Jesus himself who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
for for
e
[Music]
for for
you've owned your fear and all yourself
Lo you've owned the voes inside of your
head you've on the shame Roo of your
failure it's time to your
belov you've on the past and now it's
defined you You' everything everybody
else say it's time to hear with your
father has
spoken it's time to your beloved
and he says your mind smil when a made
you I find you beautiful in every way my
love for you is fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it
Tes my
you've on the M you seen in the
miror you the LI that you just not
enough you've been so blinded by all
your
comparing it's time to your
[Music]
belov and he says your mind smile when I
made you I find you beautiful in every
way my love for you Fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it
takes my
belov you are
completely loved and fully
[Music]
know beloved
believe me he died to make your heart
his home he says you're mine smil when I
made you I found you beautiful in every
way my love for you is fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it takes
he says you're mine I smil when I made
you I find you beautiful in every way I
love for you is fearce and an ending
I'll come to find you whatever it
takes my
belov it's time to own your belovedness
[Music]
we're so grateful that you joined us
this evening
Vicky
James I for
one and I'm sure many more are very
touched by your story and Vicki I agree
it's important to
share I have a couple of announcements
um if you're interested in being
baptized one week from today on January
the 12th we are offering a baptism class
immediately following this service
tonight it will be a fairly short class
about 20 or 30 minutes long simply head
to the Cross
room any of us can tell you where that
is uh especially if you've had a meet up
in there uh right after this service and
it's in the adult classroom
hallway save the date January 26th 6:
p.m. after church
for a class introducing you to one of
the most misunderstood letters in the
lgbtqi a plus
alphabet
transgenderism as many of you know trans
folks are being heavily politically
attacked right now so this is an
opportunity to understand more about who
they are and how we can love and support
them
and I just need to say one little thing
about my family Suzanne and I and our
immediate family have been begun
embracing
transgenderism and we have
questions because we want to fully love
and fully
understand to be clear though this is
not so much of a a class for Trans
people it is a class for the rest of us
to become more informed
sign up by scanning the QR
code and last but not least it's the
first Sunday of the month so immediately
following the service you were invited
to head over to hack Creek Burger
Company in saxi it's off Highway 78 to
connect with other folks from the table
we'd love to have you join
us all right let me send you into your
week with this
blessing you can hold out your hands in
a posture to receive or just open your
heart to these
words you are a child of
God
you are a child of
God this is true on your best
day and this is true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with the assurance that you are loved
you are
worthy you are accepted just as you are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact
with be
blessed have a good week and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday and at hat
Creek good
night and he
says smil when I made you I find you
beautiful in every way I love for
you
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it
my
Bel it's time you
[Music]